welcome back y'all my next guest is one
of the bestselling authors on the planet
since her debut novel in 2012 she has
sold over 40 million books and redefine
the fantasy genre her latest is House of
flame and Shadow the third book in her
Crescent City series this is amazing
actually just check this out how many
people actually showed up to her
midnight release party last week it's
like Taylor Swift went somewhere it's
like crazy please welcome Sarah J
Mass
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god well Welcome to our show and
congratulations oh my God I can't
believe I'm here and there are puppies
is that where they are you came on a
good day I'm taking all of them they're
all spoken for now they're all coming
home with that's actually really hard
for me not to do like I don't I have two
children and two dogs I do not need
anymore in my house but it's hard
they're so cute I know my 5-year-old son
came with me here today and he just said
to me Mommy I want snowflake um oh
that's hard I think our 14-year-old dog
at home yeah would have a heart attack
and die um if I brought home that kind
of energy is different yes cuz I brought
home Charlie to Henry and they're
they're like four years difference I
think and Henry was not impressed yeah
mm-m
yeah I let my daughter get a dog and
Henry was like what's happening here
like yeah yeah they're fine now but do
you get star strik still by authors like
that you love uh yes I cry every time I
meet someone that I really admire I I
don't know I have this reaction yeah
because I it's so intense that my body
just goes to tears yes well I think it's
when it's someone that I have admired
and whose Journey inspired my journey
yeah all of those emotions from like
wishing and hoping to like get to that
same point in my career it hits me at
once um and I'll like I'll never forget
I was at this book convention and I was
on a panel with this author Tamara
Pierce who I had like grown up reading I
loved her books and I was on a panel
with her like as a peer like that that
shouldn't happen like I am not smart or
cool enough to be sitting next to this
woman I have been in this situation
musically yes and you're like why am I
here and so I like walk in and like sit
down next to her and I just her name's
Tamara and I go hi Tammy um you're like
besties off the bat I wanted to die and
she just was like very she was so
gracious she was just like oh hello it's
nice to meet you and then I just started
telling her like I'm only here today
because of the work that you did because
of the trail that you blazed I just well
yes but I started sobbing like his like
and not and not like like beautiful
no no mine were
like and this was before a panel was
about to begin so there was a room full
of people there witnessing this like
absolute meltdown um and thankfully she
was so kind and at the end of my whole
like sobbing rant she was just like it's
very nice to meet you um you know it's
interesting though is you have now fans
that probably do that with you that you
inspire and you touch and they cry and
you're like no I get it I'm like this
with other people oh yeah know I'm like
like don't ever be embarrassed by the
tears because I am that person and the
tears are a wonderful thing like it
tells you that something yes exactly
exactly but then the like my readers
start crying and then I start crying I'm
a contagious crier as well someone cries
on the couch and I'm like oh my God over
no no done it's done the makeup's ruined
it's like I want to cry all the time
what's happening I think it's called
menopause whatever
um but you say like explaining the book
is kind of hard right that the new book
why do you think it what can you tell us
yeah so this is the third book in my
Crescent City series you don't want to
ruin anything yeah so no spoilers my
lips are sealed um but this series is
kind of like a mash up between like
fantasy paranormal romance little urban
fantasy so it's a separate fantasy world
but like a modern world so there are all
these magical creatures living in that
world and there's in lots of like action
and a lot of like very steamy stuff like
lots of hot dudes yeah um and then like
it's kind of like all my my other books
I've got a couple different Series where
they're all about like young women
finding their their strength uh saving
the day kicking butt yeah so there's
there's that uh there's a big that's a
big part of it and yeah just it must be
hard to not be able to talk about the
book though because you're like oh wait
fans might not be caught up yet yes yes
and and book two ends on a major
Cliffhanger so I can't even like explain
the beginning like just the general
premise of this third book um is that
normal by the way like last night I I
mean even vulture wrote something about
you like like you did this release and
like it just blew up it literally was
like Taylor Swit was releasing an album
like it all these people showed up is
that normal um I guess you feel like a
tool answering that is yeah I was like
wait that's a weird question but I mean
that's amazing the impa you you this was
actually my first event like in-person
event since Co um yeah so this was kind
of like my first time like back in the
flesh well by the way you're in demand
look at that like well that's you're
doing doing it right it was it was just
amazing being out there and like seeing
the readers face to face again after so
many years and um and you've created
this world like whichever series you
know they're addicted to or into like
you've created this whole world that
y'all are all a part of that's really
cool yeah no it's just it's I mean it's
still feels like a dream come true like
I wanted to be a writer since I was 16
years old that's amazing yeah yeah and
so to get to what made you want to like
what turned you on to reading in the
first place I mean I was just like a
weird kid yeah I mean I grew grew up
during a time when like liking fantasy
sci-fi was like not cool like you could
get like thrown in a trash can at school
for liking those things yes um and my
parents were big readers but they were
more like intellectual readers and so I
was this like weird changeling child who
just appeared and was like I like
fantasy and I like Star Wars and
thankfully my parents indulged that and
they you know let me kind of read where
my heart wanted to go and um by the time
I was 12 I knew that I loved reading f
to see novels and then I just quickly
realized I wanted to not just read them
I wanted to write them and I wanted to
write stories about young women like
create that kick and I don't know if I
can say ass can I say ass let's just say
it ass kick and ass kick and ass and
also like the romance like I was I
didn't really like the books I read in
school because there was never any magic
but there was really like not enough
kissing for me um oh my God your parents
probably had a ball my parents had no
idea what I was reading like my parents
had no idea or my mom had no idea what I
was listening to I was like oh yeah I'm
totally listening just Michael W Smith
mom that's it yeah I was like like which
I love by the way but I think it's a
nice one like your parents just like
they don't hover too much and they just
like let you like love the things that
you're going to love and I don't think
she let me do that she just didn't know
I was listening to TLC Red Light Special
yeah really yeah she didn't know see my
parents were just like I don't know they
there's Beauty in that and then letting
your like that you become who you're
going to become yeah my 5-year-old son
he's already the other night before we
went to the midnight release party I got
all glammed up and I came out and did
the big reveal to all my friends that
were at my house and they were all you
know so happy then my son goes you look
like an old rat um my what is it with
son so my son will judge every outfit I
wear I come down to go out with my
girlfriend's and he literally was like
oh so you're going to wear
that I'm like I was styled today by an
actual stylist
he saw me sitting in the chair for 2
hours having everything done this took
work of time and like yeah I don't know
what it is about Sons they're very
honest oh my God vicious Meanwhile my
daughter's just like you look fine mom
you look great she's like trying to like
dance on coals to make it better I know
I know know but I like I mean I guess I
like that they're bold and honest but
you know wow I didn't ask yeah I mean
old rat I was like well you know what
rats are very intelligent so I take that
as a compliment exactly turn it around
turn I like it um House of flame and
Shadow the third book and her Crescent
City series is out now and everyone is
going home with a copy you lucky
people up next we've got a musty
performance in the castol we'll be right
[Music]
[Applause]
back thank you guys
y'all have a great night I'm going
home